We're here to find a potential date for Ashley,
and Joy has narrowed it down to two guys,
and we're gonna surprise Ashley with her date,
that's why she's wearing a blindfold.
No, this show has not changed format.
We're surprising Ashley.
All right.
The remaining two, Maxwell and Matthew
now have to answer one more question each
and this time that question's coming from Joy.
Alright, Maxwell, you are up first.
Joy, will you ask Maxwell your question?
Okay, so what is your best and worst quality,
when it comes to being in a relationship?
Good question.
I'd say my best quality, like sense of humor
and ability to listen to my partner,
get along.
Worst, probably,
I can be late to things
like I'm bad at showing up on time.
I've heard of worse qualities.
Matthew, your next.
Joy will you ask your question, please?
Yeah, I'll ask the same question.
What is your best and worst quality
when it comes to being in a relationship?
So for my best,
I'd say I'm definitely like super understanding, like loyal
like big into listening
like love to just like hear what the other person has to say
or else like nothing's gonna really work out
if you're not really, it's just a one way conversation.
And you know, the worst quality is like I overthink a lot.
Like I tend to ignore my own needs and like
I have a difficulty acknowledging and addressing
like problems when they're coming up.
And I just try to like, you know, stuff in a way, but like
I understand this now, and you know I'm self-aware
so I'm definitely working on any of it.
Well that's hard to admit,
so good for being honest about yours,
I appreciate that.
Good, that's good.
We all have things we need to improve on.
That's true.
Okay, Ashley, what are your thoughts from listening?
Everyone, including Broody just seems
like down to earth nice guys.
Again, hard to gauge obviously I can't see,
we haven't really interacted, but from-
Well, you said it wasn't about looks and we put that
to the challenge.
I know, you're right,
you're right, I did.
All right.
That's the moment of truth, Joy.
Who are you going to choose for Ashley may I ask?
Okay.
I think Maxwell.
Maxwell!
(audience applauding)
Sorry Matthew.
Joy, I am just gonna say that if I had to do the choosing,
I would've made the same choice.
Really?
I really am being totally honest,
and I do think that you have your granddaughter's
best interests.
I do, I do, yes.
And Ashley, are you ready to meet Maxwell?
I am.
All right, take that blindfold off.
All right, here we go.
Hi.
Hi Ashley.
Hello.
What's up? How are you?
Wonderful to meet you.
Nice to meet you.
I'm great, I'm a little nervous,
if I can be honest.
Oh it's okay.
This is,
this is new to me.
Welcome to the club.
Oh my gosh.
Well yay, I'm so happy that I don't see anyone else,
but you look great.
You sound awesome so.
Don't worry about them.
I have to say as awkward as this is,
I'm actually thrilled with the outcome.
(audience cheering)
I'm thrilled, I'm thrilled.
Okay ladies.
Okay, now Maxwell,
now that you've actually said your ideal first date,
Ashley would you mind telling me
what your ideal first date is?
Yeah.
So first day in the city, usually a nice restaurant.
I love, I'm such a restaurant person
especially in New York, I'm always bouncing around.
So I love when the guy picks it
and it's something like somewhere I've never been to,
some place I've never been to.
So starting with that I think is
like my ideal, like first date.
Cool restaurant.
Yeah, maybe rooftop action.
Yeah.
I think that's what Maxwell said.
Rooftop.
I think you did, right?
We can skip the museum.
We'll go right to the restaurant.
We can totally do a museum yeah, I mean.
We'll save that for the second date.
I think that's a good second date spot.
Mm hm, mm hm.
I love a museum.
Not that I have anything to do with this
but I think this was really fun.
Joy, how are you feeling about it right now?
I'm great, I'm fine with it.
It sounds good.
Okay good, I'm glad.
All right, well, we would love to make sure
that dinner is taken care of.
So we're just gonna pay for that dinner
and add a bottle of champagne.
(audience applauding)
Oh my God!
On top of it,
and thanks to visa gift card, dinner is on us.
Oh thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you Joy.
You got it.
And Ashley and Maxwell, most importantly
now that you guys have gotten through this,
it'll give you a great base for conversation
on your first date.
100%.
Yes it will.
Thank you so much you guys.
(upbeat music)